hey everybody it's Josh Wolf and I am
here to tell you the story on behalf of
manscape.com the leader for men in all
things groinal and I hear they know a
thing or two about hygiene as well
here's the deal everybody needs to get
the lawnmower 4.0 the absolute ultimate
for grooming tools down under not only
do they have the lawnmower 4.0 but they
got body washes and lotions and soaps
for every part of your body they got
boxers they got T-shirts they got a lot
of different stuff it sounds kind of
great doesn't it that's because it is
you dudes who don't trim it up are
setting us back decades I bet you guys
don't even have wipes by your toilet at
the house gross you wax guys tip of the
hat to you that is a hard pass for me oh
and a flaccid boner and anybody who
tells you that you need to take a
straight razor to your balls does not
understand the Topography of a nut sack
it's like a little brain you're gonna
Nick that dude once or twice by the way
if you've never done that the first time
you do it you think you're gonna bleed
out for real I put my feet above my head
I called my dad I was like is this How
It Ends but guess what that never has to
happen to you if you order the lawnmower
4.0 from manscape.com right now get 20
off you'll also get free international
shipping two free gifts you just hit
that promo code Josh w20 that is caps
j-o-s-h-w and the number two and zero
Josh w20 hit that link below right where
I'm fingering you put that promo code
get your 20 off and let's see those
smooth nuts yeah
[Music]
not sure why you wanted to share that uh
so are you you're a nurse are you saying
he's naked
he he and he's there's nothing covering
his junk and you still can't see it
[Music]
so it retracts like a turtle
yeah yeah and is is that just like
because he's nervous like home shy
or it's cold or what is the reason that
it sinks in
it it lives like that don't say it like
that
sounds like a horror movie it lives like
that
wow
does it come out ever to be like
peek-a-boo like is there any of that
they go digging for dick
[Music]
and don't keep me as dismissed till they
find it or how does this story end I
want to know
[Music]
dude oh wait you hear what she said you
got to grab a couple of buddies
wait okay okay okay hold on wait wait
okay okay hold on
[Applause]
so it's inside like an innie belly
button and it stays in there and and and
is he in the hospital because it's in
there or it's just it's just so [ __ ]
happy accident oh okay and so when this
person gets aroused does it
you're gonna leave me hanging on that
[Music]
what if his heart on goes out his
[ __ ] because it's a [ __ ] it's like
a reversy
and it just goes you're like oh [ __ ]
when he lies he's like Pinocchio and his
dick comes out his ass
wow and so is that how you met him
[Laughter]
found it
wow I want to tell you something for
real
I know at first I was wondering why she
wanted to say that but I am so glad you
did
thank you for sharing with the class I
really appreciate that
I didn't know that was a thing but I'm
gonna [ __ ] Google the [ __ ] out of it
when I get home
any dicks I don't even
are you also a nurse
you are a medic for a long time
[Music]
hold on hold on you're gonna need a
microphone for this
okay everybody she's gonna tell you
about the buddy system for your
just in case anybody in here has got an
innie she's going to help you out hold
on
here we go this is what we do
you've got to make the triangle with
your hands and put pressure around the
basis of where the turtles hanging out
in his Cove
hold on hold on hold on I just saw you
know in this analogy the turtle is the
dick or the balls
the dick so the tucked away dick okay
can we make an analogy so the turtles
swimming around his little pool like
[Laughter]
and he's like I want to come up for air
but he's underwater he can't come up
yeah the hands are the food and they're
put on the side so maybe he'll come out
and show his face sometimes you guys
it's like Groundhog Day
is it winter when the dick comes out is
that what happens
now can I ask you something okay okay
okay can I ask you is this your
boyfriend
your husband okay he's all right dude
Ken and I know this is weird but I don't
have a good visual
will you just get can you show me the
triangle on his dick so I see what the
[ __ ] you're talking about
I know you don't have any dude she
wouldn't know about she but I just can
you yeah just can you can you just give
me a little so I can see what's
happening
I think we're all curious I think we're
all curious today
just do it on that dude instead
she's like no that's cool I'm good all
right
[Music]
wow okay
by the way anybody else have anything
they want to share
oh I can't wait to tell that story wow
yes
your husband had that
by the way so did you
[Laughter]
is that him right there oh okay yo you
see him he's like
[Music]
I got a big dick
no I'm sorry I'm sorry no no start over
start over
it does come out
okay out of his [ __ ]
oh I'm the front part yeah
is it is it okay
[Music]
I just want you to know how my brain
works I have like 180 more questions
and I'm not going to ask you any of them
I'm just going to Google them but thank
you thank you [ __ ] thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
that's how big her titties were they
made that noise through the air